uh well
um welcome to our third day of hearing
so it's great to be
here in oxford um so firstly um
we have our first admission of shirley
farrell so shirley if
you could come forward
thanks julie if you could um
we're live streaming today we live
streaming
this is it live at the moment where
we're just recording waiting for us
okay so just just
um surely um up to i see up to 15
minutes
so um which is great i'm sorry
thank you sorry um up to 15
minutes to present shirley um and
uh if you could leave some time in there
for some questions it'd be great
we are on live stream audio today so
just to let you know
that but thank you for your time and we
look forward to hearing your submission
points
thank you um
i was asked if i could spread speed a
project to actually
get it restored and i think that was
because i was involved with the
restoration of the office of jail which
is a great
asset to the um to oxford the kpops for
beautiful communities still
actually
[Applause]
um
so after that we met with uh david and
some other people and
thank you dan for organising the uh
latest options report from wwsp
which is a bit of a shock to us actually
but in 2012
the option one to close the bridge and
do what
this new one said it was only going to
cost thirty nine thousand dollars
the report that we got because a few
weeks ago is a hundred and ninety five
thousand and that's
actually closed that they dismantle it
um under option two in 2012 they thought
it was going to cost 152
000 want to repair and be able to work
on it
today that price is 520 000
in option three that we wanted to make
of walking and cycling
is 850 000.
so it's a little bit out of my league if
you actually
try and get that so the council has
known about this bridge for a long time
and it's disappointing
that nothing's been done it's listed as
a category two historic structure
and i understand he was made gifted at
the end of the bridge so it would be
able to be accessed and participated
in the 1990s when the river was in
flight
and some of the school children used to
go across the bridge they hatched with
us
structures and heritage i mean you go
and i do have hope that there are no
other heritage classified sites that
have forgotten about
that sorry just surely we're just going
to swap the mics over at the stop
it's not really bad there we are it's
okay
thank you
for the decision on what to do with it
and while it's the corpus of council's
final decision and money that will
become in that outcome
i do increase the council does have
community consultation
process in conjunction with also
historical society
to determine what the outcome will be
done now
since i wrote a little respect the other
day i actually came across
really i've been working very closely
with phoenicians
from the plus historical society
and i found a letter from the council in
written um somebody wasn't
doing it at that time and i've looked
they've looked they've looked at it
and the council has however not been
able to fund the repair of the bridge to
date
and um they've got no detailed estimates
of detailed engineering assessments that
have been prepared
regrettably there is some indication
that
council will fund the restoration there
is little point in spending skills funds
on carrying out a detailed survey and
yeast but for illustration
i do know that well after amalgamation
um some of the staff from that were
formerly officer county council actually
repeated some of that bridge because
for the children to still look over it
and
please may i assure you that despite the
lack of funding
the council is well aware of the
historical significance of the bridge
and has never proposed removing the
structure
so um yeah and it's also
in the west eden and heritage historical
thing so it's a beautiful beautiful
bridge
it was a beautiful bridge so i'm just
please give consideration to spending
some money on it
as i said personally i don't want it
dismantled but
and and also our venus last night sent
me a
an email from
heritage new zealand and this um robin
raised the senate team meeting last week
so that's the new zealand
christchurch heritage meeting and i'm
currently advising the waimakariri
district council
on the heritage asset works program
that this may be a case of retaining as
much heritage fabric of the suspension
bridge
as possible while also ensuring the
council can manage any potential health
and safety
risks i.e disabling the access
so perhaps leaving the bridge as it is
but making sure people can't look over
it
so any questions
i think is it
it's not working at all it's a bit of a
problem with our
microphones here
thank you shirley i appreciate your
points is there any questions of
colleagues from colleagues
council redmond
[Applause]
thanks for your submission um how much
would this stretch
but the way things are going with
cycleways and walkways i mean maybe we
could have a wide neckery river to the
ranges
cycleway or something i don't know but i
mean
it may not get any use but as long as
it's still there and be able to be seen
and i truly i would really like the 850
further questions council duty this is
very interesting
and i really it is important to
restore our heritage as much as possible
and i'm just trying to work out ways in
which
you know how to live in council or
outside of
council alone looking at perhaps trying
to find
a way forward to do something with it
so um
would you consider working with myself
and
and see if we can find a way of
maybe getting some money not
apart from asking accounts or looking at
outside funding of some sort
i think the council need to to find out
what
the community and heritage new zealand
want of the structure
you know there was i was thinking you
could sell boards and
you know you could do all sorts of
things but i think that
because it is owned by the council it
was gifted to the council by the world
family
and they need to work out what they want
i mean if they have started in 1996 and
put a little bit of funding away
for the for the next 25 years
we could have had a beautiful bridge
thank you for bringing this to us um i
didn't
i wasn't able to make that meeting that
you went out
myself um it really isn't quite some
disrepair and it is a shame i
i give you that um i just wanted to know
like what are the three options that
you've been given here with
the wsb brief for the
the replay structure are they talking
about just completely replacing it like
all the heritage
and just reproducing it as a replica
or is that a um
what exactly does the replace structure
option entail well i haven't really gone
into that but i mean a lot of the stains
and the towers and
actually went and and got rid of a lot
of the um
so that people couldn't work on it so
um i'm not an engineer i haven't gone
into the report very much i just took
one look
purposes wouldn't
trying to keep
the historic um
parts of this bridge intact rather than
replace them with a better option
well it could be but i i think it's up
to the council and the community to the
society
thank you for the questions
um you mentioned that your preferred
option would be to actually
fix the if at some point
is
i would like to be able to see it so
that people could walk
or even cycle across us but that's just
me
it's a community thing but as a
i don't believe people climb on it now i
mean it may be that you keep the towers
and then you have an information board
about what it looked like in the history
of it
but that stuff that's not shy
thank you shirley and it is an important
matter and
there will be a report that comes
through from staff and certainly will
follow up
um the response to bernard as well but i
agree i think it's a
it's a conversation with our community
community board and council
um about its future before we make any
decisions on it right
so i saw the report it was certainly
horrifying
because we're sort of afraid to do it
it's a shame it's got to this level but
we need to work on a way forward so
thank you for raising it
and thank you for speaking to it today
thank you
okay so um next submitter
is tedron ted
[Applause]
[Music]
and you joined good morning and welcome
um and just to remind you we're on a
live
audio stream as well so if you could
just click the button
there thank you here we go look forward
to hearing your submission thanks ted
thank you i would just like to to
ask first of all that if there are any
questions of me
i take my hearing aid now i get an echo
in here and it's very difficult to
hear what what the questions may be so
i'll try and
be exclusive as i can be but i hope that
you can bear with me a little bit
and i cannot read my notes so i cannot
refer back to him
sorry okay okay sorry the
mic's not working at the top
the system is we're having a few
technical issues this morning
hold on hold on a minute we'll just um
there we are
thank you thank you
and what i'd like to say is that um with
regards to
the submission from the blind division
and senior citizens and concerned
parents
we have been following up these
submissions over a number of years
five years now and asking
that the council consider a speed
reduction
through the main area of the township
to enable local residents to be more
able safely to access crossing the road
using the pedestrian crossings
and if this situation
is actually not diminishing we have
an aged population in
oxford you need to access both sides of
the road
from the pharmacy to supermarket the
medical center
and all of those community assets like
the cafes and the shops
we have also got a situation
where we have an increasing amount of
heavy traffic
coming through the main street of oxford
combination of those things are that
when we
are trying to access across the
pedestrian crossings
it is increasingly more intimidating i
realize that for people who are more
mobile much younger is not as so much of
a problem
but in oxford and with the business
visions in this
defined area and needing to access them
and needing to participate within the
community
we're finding it increasingly difficult
and fraud but the simple reason that the
traffic
is coming through in the main
at the maximum speed or only just a
little below we know that the
council have taken on board at the door
speed monitoring
and the average is just a little under
the 50k
but that also does not allow for the
fact that there are some
that are going over the 50k it is a mean
speed so therefore there is that
would be us asking to reduce speed
to possibly 40. our concern is that at
those speeds that would be heavy trucks
and trainers going through which are
exceeding
and a lot of the older and more
vulnerable sector of our community are
now actually pulling back from wanting
to go
over the victory
trucks and trailers and heavy vehicles
going through at those speeds
when the roads come fishy and when
they're not busy
are less able to take proactive action
if someone happens to be daunting a lot
of pedestrian crossing
or for whatever reason they happen to be
there we
have a situation where such as myself
i cannot judge traffic at all i cannot
see it
clearly enough something that may be
some distance away
at 50 k's and this is the same for the
older
age people who take a long life across
that pedestrian crossing
something that is coming towards you at
50k
approaches and it comes on top of you
very quickly we have a situation that a
lot of traffic do take notice and
believe
in the pedestrian crossings they will
stop when they're able
an awful lot do not and they're
traveling 50 cases they
sort of come across a pedestrian
crossing and say oops
i can't stop and they keep going which
is exceedingly intimidating is also
against the rules really the
situation then becomes that you have to
wait to cross the pedestrian crossing we
are subject to having to wait for
someone to decide whether they're going
to stop for us or not
we also have a situation in many cases
where someone gets halfway across
the traffic coming towards us they can't
bother to stop or they're going too fast
and they keep going so you might be
halfway across your pedestrian crossing
and all of a sudden someone's come along
behind you and they've gone past you
they're not supposed to do that either
that the whole package
from our point of view is this we are
asking please for a little bit of
consideration
we know that the council do not
legally have to sort out permission to
lower the speed limit within the oxford
confines
we are quite a unique area in a small
business
area and getting increasingly kids here
we have a lot of people we've got the
rickwood which is on one side we have
the
mayor place residents to be all the
people on the other we all have to cross
and use that excess we cannot say
features
and we're just asking is it not possible
please
to consider that you would reduce the
speed limit to 40k
this would give traffic on through
traffic
a much much better able
to assess the situation as they're
approaching those pedestrian crossings
it would give us if we are on the
pedestrian crossing at that point in
time
a little bit more time to safely cross
over
without having to worry about vehicles
coming and intimidating those coming
down the main street
now i have many many people i've talked
to many people around oxford and they
will tell you
how many new misses they
perceive during a working day it's quite
considerable if you actually make
the uh if you take the top of the
question people involved in
i have actually taken the trouble to
discuss more to ask
all of the businesses within the
confines of the town centre
and there are about 12 that i've spoken
to they have
all said they would be very
very see a reduction in speed
with the traffic accessing from the
supermarket from the side roads
and through traffic is an exceedingly
busy and potentially more and more
dangerous
every day so
again i'm afraid that's all that i can
say off the top of my head
i would like to say too that the
waimakariri district council
we are members of the wider
access group the disability group my age
is with the council we're talking about
these sort of
issues constantly so far we haven't had
a
very very suitable response with regards
to
oxford the waimakariri district council
also uses
its publicity the fact that they have
now signed up to the unesco
age age-friendly communities
this also takes into account people's
of age concerns within the communities
so that is another reason why we're
asking
please take all of those issues on board
and consider it
we have met up with numerous people from
the
council over the years aside agents
not always
slightly sort of disingenuously said
well
if you're so concerned about crossing
his pedestrian crossing why don't you
wear a high-vis vest
which i felt was a little bit
nonsensical really and it's a bit unique
so taking all of those issues
and concerns and the fact that we are
as a public in oxford exceeding this
and i know that children mothers and
parents with young children who are very
concerned
with their children being able to cross
these pedestrian crossings
i will point out to you the fact that
the land transport
authority actually does state
that vehicles approaching
the history of crossing should be
traveling
at a low enough speed to be able
to observe the companies are going to
cross
on the internet and therefore must be
able to slow down
and be able to stop to enable the people
to cross over
i spoke to a lady yesterday
she's on a mobility but she doesn't have
low vision
and but
three vehicles totally ignored her
because they were traveling at speed
through the pedestrian company two days
previously she said
she was at the supermarket and wanted to
across she got halfway across
and some people came up behind couldn't
be bothered to slow down and stop and
just carry on through behind
them that sort of response
from the traffic users is not good so we
are asking the council
in this instance please put the agent
the community at large put their
responses
over that the vulnerable people the
pedestrians
over about the needs and aspirations of
the transport
people i would ask also whether the
council has had lobbying from the
transport
users we have
[Applause]
it is a very difficult one i realize
we're not asking for a big lot
but 10k will give all of us a little bit
more time
and opportunity to be aware of where we
are where we're at
and for people to take the necessary
attitude to spoke
out stop and make it a safe community
thank you very much
thanks t and could i just say before
there may be some quick can you hear me
okay
can you hear me so what um we're about
to
go through our district with some speed
reviews and
because of the number of submissions and
and i'm aware of the public opinion
i've asked our writing staff to include
this area
again for a review um so that'll be
happening in the near not too distant
future so just to let you know that we
have asked our staff
to again consider as a as an authority
we
we don't have the sole decision on speed
limits but we can
design the process working with nzta and
other bodies but
just to let you know that will happen
and when that does occur
we'll make you aware of that so you can
um speak to that
as well we'll certainly include your
submission and the other
points in that process but we'll let you
know when that happens
and be happy to make sure that we come
out and hear
the community's opinion on that okay
thank you yes
yes that's fine yeah i'm very happy for
that yeah okay
um maria could you just put the mic
sorry
we're having a few issues with the mines
here this morning so
i'm sorry about that but i'll start
there's very little we can do about so
that's a technical issue but
if it clicks off just give them another
click
okay so i'm maria um i've lived in 15
years
16 years now i'm an ex-ambulance
um officer concerns that have been
raised from parents
um up speed in the oxford township
is a lot easier
untitled amount of trucks and trailers
logging trucks
transport trucks i'm going to run off of
that together for you
um a lot of these guys um
are on their phones when they're coming
through township so they're not
every professional truck driver myself
you're coming into oxford
you've got a pedestrian crossing in the
center by the supermarket
coming in from this way you've got to
look at the hazards of what's going on
around you you've got two intersections
you've got flags outside
businesses you've got plantings around
the pedestrian costumes you've got
cars coming out of the supermarket then
you might have a little five-year-old
kid
standing at the district crossing you're
not going to see that
until you're right on top of it um these
logging trucks
did i say i followed one the other day
he was still doing 68 cases when he was
coming down from the west end
i slowed down the 50 by the time i got
to the supermarket
it'd go around the corner by the
cemetery
um the speed that these trucks and a lot
of cars are doing
is it's going to cause someone to be
killed
um there's a pedestrian hit and lower
this morning
um the chances are you know you don't
know what's around the corner
but if we don't look at
just in the speed in the township now
there is going to be a death
there are a lot more kids and the life
of ted
you know not being able to see that well
you've got
the people from the retirement home
across the road from
the supermarket those people are
terrified
they see these logging trucks flying
through and they're like how the hell
are we ever going to get across that
road
um you know they've witnessed it um
cassandra and i we've done a petition
outside of gif a51 for the fireside
the three days we stayed out there for
like eight nine hours
and i tell you what i don't know how
many times i really needed my first day
to get
the close encounters that happen
you know it's easy to say oh i sit and
watch
a pedestrian crossings burned out and
nothing happened
there are certain times of the day when
the log-in trucks come through there's
certain times in the day when
people are speeding to get your kids to
school on time
um for us if you want us to do a
petition i'll go ahead and do that
could guarantee you i could get a hell
of a lot of signatures
to get the speed reduced i would like to
actually see
the actual pedestrian crossings raised
i know as a professional truck driver
that would piss you off and they would
take off down south yeah
and that would be a godsend for this
township
um you know the safety of our elderly or
their young
we need these pedestrian crossings
raised and we need this bed reduced
from either high street down here at the
gas station through to the challenge
you drop that to a 30k 40k
those lock-in trucks then have got to
look at
you know i mean these guys are
professional drivers they've been doing
that for years ago
but we've got young kids we've got
five-year-olds that walk to school every
day on their own
your points are well made and i can i
just say on behalf of council we do take
it seriously
don't need you to do a petition with us
you're welcome to if you wish
we will get the speeds looked at but
there are other solutions i'd like our
road safety team to look
into including a suggestion at the
community board the other night around a
pace car
talking to the heavy vehicle
users because there was a successful
model that was
undertaken in woody and some years ago
so there are a range of things that can
be done
but i know speed speeds i know there's a
place vehicle that does cusp
and i was behind it one day i had a
vlogging i mean i was in my
week car
[Music]
i think you've spoken well both of you
actually are there any questions of
colleagues and there was
it was some um really good points made
at the community board the other night
so we will follow those those three
council duty yeah thank you for
listening
hold on just teach us for one minute
the trapping
[Music]
because he's
um you know something serious is going
to happen and i don't want it to be to
that
okay okay council duties offered to
organise there
but i think working in conjunction with
our road safety team
is the fact that it is a very short
distance in the township of oxford
the actual journey time maximum
would be increased by one minute
by reducing the speed to 40k
now i do not see how the trucking
companies
can say that that is interfering and
upsetting their working day one minute
so they say we have a much much more
vulnerable community having to try
to make excuses
for those businesses we have the high
street of rangiora which is a similar
situation in as much as it is remain
through road
from the oxford road going through the
end we cannot get any trucks through
there they can't get through there but
the waimakariri district council puts in
the majority
of issues to enable the pedestrians and
the businesses to operate
safely you've got a slow movement of
traffic through there at every one of
those
intersections with pedestrian crossings
because of the slow speed of that
traffic
there is courtesy they stop and allow
people to go
over and no one is really threatened
what we're asking for
is a reduction of 10ks in the opposite
community
in a very short distance it's not going
to interfere with those businesses
or their assets in any way shape or form
all it's going to do
is make it a little safer for the
community
in oxford or all of those countries
and enable us to go about our business
and enjoy the amenities within our own
small
little business community thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
maria we appreciate your time
your points have been well made and uh
we will be back in touch with you about
our next stage in the process but in
terms of
our hearing process um we will be
considering
submissions towards the end this month
and in the month of july we'll be
releasing
releasing our decisions on that so just
to let you know in terms of this process
but
the speed review would take um take a
different process outside of the ltp
but we'll be back in touch thank you for
your time we appreciate it thank you for
listening to us
appreciate it thank you connect
we have the oxford arts trust aretha
good morning good morning so just i
brought emma
as well oh great hello anna welcome
welcome along
just on the um mics but we are on live
audio streams if we could use that so
there are
uh quite possibly people listening at
the moment outside
that would love to hear what's being
said this morning and also we're
recording it so
um just click the button and you've got
up to 15 minutes
and if you could leave some time within
that for questions i might give you a
bit of an indication of
about 10 minutes on if that's right for
you thank you
my name is arita wilkinson and i'm the
chair of oxford arts trust
um and anna white has a volunteer
providing role support
uh to quickly share my background i'm an
artist of my identity husband
i hold her phd in creative arts i work
for montgomery with design strategy
two years for multiple players and
currently for i cover
i was a member of the nigeria technical
jet
strategy group for toronto my sister
created in new zealand
as required i'm on the maori advisory
board for the arts center
and on the main date of brexit for one
of them
on the littleton design panel
um our not-for-profit act
is a strong community and council
relationships grown over the last 10
years
the governance of our trust has
benefited from both new good and keep
impossible
guidance the wider wdc recreation
program
as an angle staple
wd creative community supports our
workshops
and the oxford hoba community board have
contributed to our facility
thank you it is because we're so
interconnected
that all starts plus can seek more
opportunity for arts cultural heritage
in the draft long-term plan so for my
older submission to emphasize the things
i
think are most important i will focus on
how the gallery can help the council to
achieve its community outcomes
the opportunity for council to increase
its supports for arts culture and
heritage
what support oit would like to see in
the district
and specific support that's not
certainly like to request
to do this work so it's great to see a
strong emphasis on community outcomes in
the draft ltp
the arts community are uniquely
well positioned as partner to help
council deliver community outcomes to
climate communities creative new zealand
has the compelling evidence through
national surveys that confirm these
well-beings
engagement in the arts improves the
lives of new zealanders
distinctive and dynamic new zealand arts
reflect the diversity of who we are
and grow our reputation as a creative
nation
engagement in the arts strengthens
whanau communities and society
the arts sector contributes to
prosperous and
civilian communities so generally taking
part in artistic and cultural activity
can increase social cohesion
help people to create networks and find
a sense of belonging
this benefits our physical and mental
health
creates a more highly skilled workforce
and to both attract tourism
and talent in the history and i've
uh closely seen the early statements
with the evidence for you
our arts mustafa gallery with the arts
community and helped council
to achieve its community outcomes and we
can
we've got a real problem with these
things this morning so apologies for it
we'll
we'll deal with it outside of this
might be in it might be a long-term
clean submission to replace that
feel free to edit in if you'd like you
go for it
yeah what's going on
thank you it's great
to achieve its community outcomes and we
can do this by
regarding public spaces page two of my
submission
we can assist the public realm design
opportunities
to create buildings that are useful and
meaningful
we can help identify integrated art
opportunities
to tell the unique stories of our people
and region
with public programs to increase
visitation of public spaces
regarding healthy sustainability
environments
h3 we can develop arts programming
through storytelling and creativity
to encourage people to participate in
our environment
and feel connected to the natural world
regarding communities cultures page
three
our gallery has experience in developing
cultural exclusion
and we know how to provide attractive
and innovative cultural experiences
regarding intel physical health and
social services page four
we can provide ongoing opportunities for
community participation in the arts
statistics show two or more hours per
week of arts engagement
is associated with new well-being mental
well-being
regarding businesses in the district our
district has a rich source of artists
practitioners and creative entrepreneurs
we can help the council understand this
economic value of this cultural market
give more visibility to the sector and
provide support
regarding opportunities for learning and
being informed page five
we can provide the cultural centre and
art specialists
of the creative industries for applied
learning
to complement educational facilities and
libraries
regarding distinctive character of our
takiwa page five
we have the relationships and needles to
develop
and celebrate narratives of our taking
life
stress built over or untold
regarding principles of the treaty of
waitangi
pages
need to hear to see and feel the effects
of these principles
visibility of our cultural identities in
the public realm
is one initiative and we have a
relationship
in the art specialists who governs work
um so what is the opportunity for
council
in order to achieve the community
outcomes council has outlawed outlined
over the next 10 years of the ltp
there is an opportunity for council to
increase its investment and arts
cultural heritage
and work in partnership with the arts
community to deliver the
ltv outcomes
there are skills and expertise in our
district on our trustables alone we have
the skills
in art policy strategy and review arts
funding
and arts and best continuum past
experience for food
design consultancy environmental art and
architectural solutions
but many groups and organizations are
largely volunteer-based
seven trusts and one activity are
working in the arts culture heritage
sector
and contributing to community wellbeing
more support is needed to make this
switch sustainable and deliver outcomes
to more of the community what's
important oh you like to see in the
district
regarding decision-making page 2-3
oit would like to see the establishment
of an arts culture and heritage
portfolio
is an additional key responsibility of
council
and that roles within council are
created with an arts focus
the arts is critical to the well-beings
because it can contribute
across most of the community outcomes of
the consultation document
in addition oit supports the initiative
of an
arts cultural inheritance strategy as a
career framework for council
having experts in the arts sector
ourselves
our gallery would like to contribute to
the strategy
through consultation and review with
direct rememberation
to give effect to the strategy we would
add that an arts team
is specifically funded to support the
local arts community
and deliver these community outcomes and
activities
arsenal gallery would like to offer a
partnership relationship with council as
part of this
arts team to look to deliver outcomes
again with correct remuneration
collaborative initiatives are in
alignment with many grants available
right now
aimed to incentivize strategic
partnerships and wellbeing outcomes
and we can work on this together
what specific support would we like to
request for the arts announcement
arsenal gary douglas from other
community areas in the district
we are an art centre nova stater
exhibition space display
art group our focus is on increasing
community engagement to foster
creativity
with audiences but also actively
developing the art sector so it can grow
a project open house is one successful
example
really developed others to create your
own workshop resources
to teach to make a living
and we have an online video useful for
coping
so jenna to deliver community outcomes
ask the lots of gallery now
needs the relationship of council and
finance
art directors of new zealand confirm
that cultural arts centres like ours can
only be supported through national and
regional government funding and grants
the volunteer model is not sustainable
and profit-making business models are
incompatible for these social outcomes
our skilled core team can't continue to
do this level of work for nothing
our trained workers are fatigued and
have no security
our gallery needs protected paid
staffing to deliver
community outcomes this is specific
support we need
one we'd like our competent admin staff
supported so that they can continue to
provide robust operational assistance
for our art centre voluntary team and
this equates to a 1.0 fte position
increasing to 2.0 within three years
to deliver to community outcomes
and extend these further into the region
we would like you to support our arts
team
composed arts engagement strategy lead
arts project manager and ask curator and
this will equate to a 1.5 eta position
for the first year
initially increasing to 3.00 in three
years
critically number three we ask for a
partnership
council to secure long-term investment
funding
and art frontier project funding
for those asks
finally the creative new zealand
ministry of cultural heritage around the
foundation
the arts cultural heritage sector has
come of age
and needs to be recognised as value for
its contribution to the growing
vulnerability
discipline arts and oxford gallery can
help council to deliver community
outcomes to own academic communities we
would like
wdc to give us financial security
for our art center for 10 years so we
can make a positive outcome
a positive contribution towards an
empowered community that is connected
healthy and prosperous thank you for
your time
thank you erica made your points really
well just a couple of things is
its culture and heritage portfolio that
is something that we are
i've had some draft terms of reference
prepared i have someone in mind or our
council
council blakely actually that may take
up that
but that will be a matter for council to
decide and uh it would be council
blacky's job
if the council agrees with that to help
um develop a strategy in that space for
our staff so
just to let you know that those things
are in trying at present
um questions from colleagues
i think you've put your points really
well and succinctly and we appreciate
the clarity of your thinking
um and and also the work that the
gallery does do
you in particular i think are doing an
excellent job
and your team there and the the quality
of exhibitions you're getting at the
gallery are
fantastic which is really putting it on
the map so
you've certainly taken it to the next
level and we appreciate all that you and
the team are doing
um
indeed we understand
we understand thank you so much um
we will be considering on submissions
our later part of this month
and in the month of july we'll be able
to communicate those so
just to let you know of our next steps
so thank you for your time this morning
thank you both thanks
okay so we next have um hospitality new
zealand peter morrison
it's like you might have someone we
recognize bob as well
if
nice to see you all too you're looking
very relaxed
um
i hope you make the most of our
hospitality venues whilst you're out
here
[Applause]
yep thank you i think counts to do is
offering you some perv
we we all enjoy it very much the um
apricot jam with cheese scone is quite a
revelation i have to say
um anyway um after 15 minutes we've got
audio um live stream as well so just to
let you know that but
um if you could leave a little bit of
time in that questions that would be
appreciated thank you
so angry morrison of the canterbury
branch
of uh new zealand i'm also a board
member
of the new zealand board
and oscar town new zealand is a
minimally nonprofit organization
and we represent approximately 3000
businesses throughout new zealand
and in canterbury we represent 350
uh businesses that include
all over canberra so we present uh to
five different councils price church
running remember selling an ash dude
so um we probably the the branch has
more most councils that we deal with
but thank you for letting us talk to you
today um
it's great to come up with a lovely chop
up here from christchurch
and tesla you're welcome any time
we actually look divine properly
so we're 119 years old in new zealand
and we advocate on behalf of the
hospital tourism sector
and we have a chief executive julie
white who's based in london with our
national office in wellington and we
have a team of seven regional ministers
and we apart from us there's another 19
global branches throughout the country
um as you know
rates is always an issue and in these
covert times any commercial rate
increase is going to cause stress to our
members
throughout your um hospitality houston
new zealand urges caution around rates
increases
while we are supportive of your projects
we do not think businesses should carry
an unfair
portion of the rates bill a deferential
is not clearly distributing the costs
that cover council operations
and amenities have many times offer more
value to residents
than they do to businesses
infrastructure funding
local councils in some parts of the
country have recognised infrastructure
funding
as a significant issue and that will
induce change
some councils are looking at targeted
rates while others have been openly
criticized
funding investments options put forward
by the government
in 2019 you will know that the private
productivity commission
until this report is widely done with
funding and finance
the report recommended better use of
existing tools and central government
funds
should be enough to close the tourism
funding shortfall
given the small start of the funding gap
introducing new funding tools will incur
significant
implementation administration and
enforcement costs
it is unlikely to resolve an immediate
benefit to councils
we endorse those segments rather
introducing new tools as for targets for
civic acceptance councils should make
previous existing tools
to achieve their goals hospitality new
zealand leaves a consistent and very
nationwide approach to the funding for
the funding of core infrastructure needs
to be introduced
hospitality and accommodation sectors
are viewed by some local councils as an
easy source of funds
by targeting rates on commercial
businesses or able to beat taxes
hospital new zealand opposes the
introduction of the detector that takes
only those
standard commercial accommodation
it's interesting that on the cv this
week uh mr
tourism stuart nash stated on hoskins
a number of times that under his watch
will be known being taxed
but he did not leave out the councils to
do it on their own court
so that was very interesting if a
targeted rate or a visibility isn't
necessary
hospitality new zealand believes that
these must be broad-based taxes
ensure and ensure that they're
appropriately designed are fair and
equivalent
equitable to those contributing have
committed support and our
used funding initiatives that benefit
the best prisoner
economy alternatively these funds must
be bring fenced and using the bill for
those who
contributed to the fund our hospital
museum's preference would be for any
funding tourism
structure to come from a centralized
pool
hospitality museum arrangements due to
the considerations given to women that
the productivity of
commissioners report findings
prior to covert tourism was struggling
to maintain
the social licensing communities in
particular infrastructure pressure
tourism growth was placing on some
regions we recognised that tourism and
hospitality use independent
for a wide variety of mixed use
infrastructure we now have a real
opportunity
to resolve some of those infrastructure
issues and prepare for rebuild of
our sector targeted rates i'm repeating
myself here that's required target rates
and tourism will be taxes
consume our members you are sued those
aren't these
unfairly basic burden of funding
infrastructure and operation on just one
part of the tourism hospitality industry
i always refer you as the the butcher
the baker candles that make everyone
makes money out of tourism it's not just
the hotel or the restaurant
and the bar it's everyone that's advice
supplies of
the hotel bar and the restaurant
everyone that comes into the city
or town taxis et cetera they all make
money out of tourism so
surely detection should not just go on
outside of the industry as rate class
businesses oppose
increased rates to fund basic
infrastructure they may not receive
direct benefit from i.e infrastructure
of freedom campus
we would reporters prefer to see central
government funding infrastructure where
local councils are unable to fund it
themselves
development should contribute
alcohol policies are lacks but we are
very happy with
the waimakariri and what they've done
over the past few years
and administering it very well
no i just i know that it's part of
submission um
to talk about laps but really
but as an operator operator um it's
working
very well for us out here through the
six year review
of things thank you
i think now that we've had the policy in
place since 2012
and my operators
are quite comfortable with what it works
but just with what peter mentioned
as far as the big taxes and things go
too and i can just
before he continues just to recap that
because hotel association is now part of
the hospitality in new zealand as well
i just want to reiterate to you guys in
a live motel
i know that hotel in general has
struggled a little bit since cove had
seen
during copenhagen a lot but coming out
of there the motels in particular and
not that we have a lot of hotels in my
career but those guys are really really
hurting
um you know we hear about they're
talking
billions of dollars in auckland um
um
right now we're not um but you might
just be introduced to
uh i would be introduced to them because
i have a number of the motel
operators contact me during the covert
period
um and posted concerned about the
revenue and
they were talking about the iniquity
with bnb operations
great if you could cover that it would
be appreciated thank you so that's our
first thing
in christchurch we're just going through
um
in christchurch last year 2019 so
it was a 50 million dollars that went to
evmb and that's money that hasn't gone
to
commercial operators as
[Music]
there's been a significant growth in
short-term accommodations
through such
commercial versus non-commercial rates
and regulation
these strata operators do not require
the same building in operational
compliance
and people who come and track the
associated costs that commission
accommodation
providers do however they do mean for
friends like tourism promotion which is
often funded from the tourism
and accommodation segment and shower
operators also have a
impact on the communities they operate
in contributing to housing children just
noise impacts and loss of community
and it states how much the new zealand
has lost
to the commercial they've been paying
commercial rates employing staff
paying taxes for many many years
um hospitality museum alongside other
sector associations some men
someone related to mdi in july 2020
recommending a compulsory registration
data sharing system that allows for
information collection from all
operators of short-term accommodation
and consistent
national regulatory framework
hospitality would like
would welcome the opportunity to work
with you and related parties to define
commercial accommodation in your area in
a way that captures people who are
benefiting from straw house meeting on a
commercial level
ensure rates are properly collected from
these businesses
ensure for appropriate health and safety
and compliance
requirements on peer-to-peer house
learning is set at the national level
remove the need for local councils again
to become involved in the rules
and advocate for central government to
create a national register of short-term
rental accommodation properties
moving towards fear regulation of
australia operators
we we were getting pride prior to cover
we were talking
to the eye about so it was going forward
but
[Music]
around the country to put pressure on
you know
i would talk about a counselor to do the
right things but
it should be a central government to do
but we need to support
the government association to get that
happening just a couple of minutes yeah
i won't go on anymore
um and
so i really just want to thank you for
the opportunity to provide important to
your consultation and we
have discussed
thank you for your thoughts they're very
helpful to us
deeply americans
um just interested in a couple of things
really
number one you talk about national rules
yet when you're submitting to us you
were talking about the fact that
in this district we don't have a problem
if you had national rules
how would your organisation see that
individual councils or
individual things that don't have
problems are
if it's a tourist in new zealand
traveling around
one of these drinks one o'clock in the
morning and then he comes to uh
timberwolves you know we're only five
million people we don't need
we don't need to have separate rules and
that's just an example but that's what i
mean
i've talked about that this is a huge
but the other thing that um that i i
just have a question on and i'm i'm a
bit concerned about
number 21 in your submission you talk
about
laps and making rules around them and
there's your organization suggesting
that
like the legislation says that that
licensing is driven
should be driven by the community so
if you can choose to have a landlord
converted here and as
um however if we remove that
does that not take away the voice of the
community that says
hey you should have it back we shouldn't
have these should be the
exactly what the legislation is designed
to do what we're saying here is that
some councils attempt to include rules
within a lab
that are not in authority to do when you
read the
actual act
[Applause]
um
different it's a slightly different
population thanks and
you know a little cpd but so they've got
other issues
um deeper so i do agree that the global
independence is good
[Music]
um properties
yep how do we do that from an amplifier
well there is there is a um there's a
plate think about their dna
so you can you can actually find all the
properties that are
because
which
they've done today i'm going to make a
network policy
90 days
if you can't go over 90 days i think
you've
got 90 days you're not deemed as
commercial
are we able to access the data to
determine whether someone is
because the people that in the
in the residential area and also
commercial operators motels in those
areas
would have regulated and they were
killed so and so once it became
self-releasing
once once people knew that whether they
okay we are running over time but
colleagues
have indicated two quick two quick
questions council barna
and council duty thank you thanks
affordable accommodations just about
impossible except for airbnb
has the industry looked at addressing
as i said we're not against we just want
a more illegal playing field you know
there's a plaque different place between
the opinion book of action all those
places
so it's just when they take uh in one
year they're taking 50 billion
in christchurch for example and i
suppose
if
a
[Music]
because that
look peter thank you and the points you
made were made by our local
operators and finding a solution to that
is
is not easy um but it was about the same
legal playing field with the compliance
as you phrase so
but we appreciate the time thank you for
coming thank you bob i'm sorry i
forgot your name but you're welcome
and i hope you continue in your
employment and
which is great to see and um to enjoy
the hospitality operators on your way
back
bob knows a few good places around the
district so i'm sure you'll introduce
you to those thank you so much
thanks a few times
thank you so much next week
you're welcome to join as well chris if
you wish
do you want to join us
all right um thank you linda we
appreciate your time we've got
um up to 15 minutes here for you so
don't have to
don't have to use all that time um but
um that's available to you
um and if you could allow some time for
questions i'll give you an indication
about
the 10 past um if you're at that point
so we may be able to ask some questions
there
you are on live audio stream as well
just to let you know so if you could
um just use your mic as you are
some reason it seems to keep clicking
off so um
the staff will try and keep an eye on it
but if you see you can just give it
another
preset technology
thank you welcome thank you i have
um
oh this is your latest one right now
okay
it will be circulated to us thank you
i don't like to see it i'm reading that
thank you that's it okay thank you very
much for inviting me
kobe has been a wake-up call throughout
the world not just here in new zealand
there is uncertainty about the economy
certainly as the previous speakers have
said
whilst new zealand appears to have fared
well that is not the time
to embark on big projects i feel
that are both costly and add to the
carbon
footprint of the council the projects
you have in mind
will not bring universal benefit to your
ratepayers
who would be happy to know that their
basic services
are secure and that existing major
projects are on track
for a satisfactory and audited
conclusion
the sports centre has required a major
loan
that requires servicing and ongoing cost
to rate payers for years
you have added the prospect of
supporting iraqi or a tennis club to
upgrade their facilities
dependent on their craft raising the
contribution
if the tennis courts are to be drained
on this 10-year program
and not slipped onto fire rate payers
will need to know
this 10-year plan could be more
reassuring
if we were informed how well you fed on
previous run
on your previous consultation for
instance i recall
there was some 30 000 dollars enough
for weed control and
i realized that this is something which
aesthetically may have to be considered
but it is an ongoing expense
it doesn't seem to have been included in
this budget
and now the data on the damage done to
human health
and the vital microbiota the soil from
dry crossing that you turbulence
is mounting up you cannot deny it you
really need to be looking
for alternative
there's no doubt that sea level is
rising
and coastal regions will be at risk the
cost of building on land that is likely
to be inundated
in 20 or 30 years should not be carried
by the inland population
these properties will at some time
become uninsurable
has the council considered its potential
liability
as the granter of building consensus
pegasus and similar coastal regions will
be one such
area their design was driven by
aesthetics
not common sense an attractive entrance
to the estate
does create an attractive entrance
but in the event of a current evacuation
it could be lethal
to make the council responsible for the
cost of community facility
in an at-risk area is not prudent even
if it is
marginally better placed in ravenswood
than the pegasus township
surely the developers should be footing
the bill for community
facilities as part of their consent
conditions improving rolling in this
area
would better serve the population and
should have been part of those
consenting conditions for development
a wooden bypass is probably a national
project as it involves the state harmony
but planning to further develop housing
and the need for an increased traffic
firm would seem
wise especially if subsequently
the bypass makes the whole
positioning of the buying of the bypass
more difficult to locate
then coming to traffic and parking if
the
proposals you make the park and ride and
the extension of public transport
are successful there should be fewer
cars looking for parking in a township
the land designated for the car park
could be much better used to provide
very high need high density
accommodation
for those people who apparently have to
commute in
town to work i like the idea of your
city center as
a gracious place to work from
but is that what your ratepayers really
want to pay for
they already have access to the
facilities you tempt us with
museum art gallery performance area
the additional office space indicates
you're planning
an increase in starting levels in the
event
of these being essential and to release
the old council chamber back to its
original pre-code room
additional offices could be provided at
a fraction of the cost
alongside the existing buildings outside
the library
if you really want to press each project
that will ultimately save
ratepayers money invest in a plastic
film recycling facility
thus lowering your landfill costs
providing secure
long-term employment for the very value
to your workers
and in enabling an income from
other neighboring authorities and
manufacturers
then i come to the issue of three waters
where clearly it does mean a loss of
control
for the council um but
it seems likely that the whole business
of collecting
water treatment delivery and disposal
of the water over the whole of the south
island's life plan
should be collected under one
umbrella group as it is in fact in most
eu
countries because it breeds efficiency
no one owns water but we all need it
and the provision of the infrastructure
that delivers it
and removes the contamination all costs
separate from the issue of ownership
which is not in dispute
it can be better managed if there are no
breaks in the organizational
responsibility for it
the recent problem with lead
contamination demonstrates
expensive upgrades of infrastructure are
long
overdue because the existing management
has had to be
responding to emergencies without the
wider funding required
to complete the review of the whole
system
which is now aging and suffering from
seismic movement
redundancies will almost certainly be
taken up in the workforce of the new
organization
so my main point i suppose is your
ratepayers will be much more impressed
by economy and prudence rather than
further projects
which do not fully address the pressing
issues that should be on
all bureaucrats mind that of global
warming
and climate change and the degradation
of our environment
thank you thank you linda uh
question uh council written
you are alumni
thank you for your submission just
referring to three waters
you make a couple of suggestions could
you clarify
you say much of how desperate water
comes from
outside the district and i want
you to clarify that coming and secondly
you refer to
i think you're inferring that the
council's infrastructure
do you have any information to support
that assertion
well from the obsolescence um
i think that the very fact that the
the problem of the lead contamination
came because an old method of joining
the
the pipe work was from using
solder which contains lead
linda can we just clarify the salient
district
and i believe i believe that that
infrastructure is still existing in
parts of this district
not not as far as we're here all ours
has been upgraded we've spent over 100
million over the last 20 years making
sure ours are
up to date and then i stand correctly
thank you but there is still this issue
of seismic
movement along my own road bay road
we had a leak in the main water pipe
there
last year okay it's now being corrected
but that doesn't mean to say that there
are little leaks going on
which may not have been registered
the movement we have had will disrupt
any joint
so i certainly stand corrected if we no
longer have those
very old junctions but
assure you we don't but i'm much
relieved to hear it
um we would be probably one of the
other authorities but we're very proud
of our infrastructure and the work that
our team
do in this space we have our own water
unit we work really hard to make sure
that our infrastructure is up-to-date
and i commend you for it
the whole of the canterbury plain
was once the wandering path of our main
rivers
and even now hydrologists find it
a challenge to locate where the
underground movement of water
is flowing most of that water comes from
the mountains
and the hydrologist that i
heard speak some two or three years ago
said that water was
fairly secure in its
delivery but the one thing that was
going to be
a threat with drought conditions to
climate change
with the hillside lowland
sources so rivers like the ashley served
by
lowland hills rather than the mountains
are
almost certainly going to dry up in the
next 10 years
and this was information from ecamm's
hydrologist
so our sources of water are
unpredictable
they're all coming from over on the
mountains
all the the reliable sources are coming
from the mountains
and that flow is coming not in the
visible rivers
but underneath running through the
gravels which is why
paul christchurch picks up all the
contamination from the farming
on the canterbury plains that movement
is it's a movement
it's not always in the same pathways
so our water supplies
are coming from outside our area our
reliable water supplies
okay thank you any further questions
linda thank you for your reflections and
thoughts we look forward to
um got a copy of your submission as well
so thank you
but we appreciate you taking the time to
come to speak to us and
letting us know your thoughts thank you
very much so at the end of this month
we'll be making
decisions on submissions and during the
month of july we expect to be able to
communicate that
um to you what their decisions are and i
hope i've set the seat for a few
bits of blue sky thinking in terms of
the car park which i don't think is
necessarily going to be
a high priority and certainly not the
civic center
we we always appreciate the reflections
and thoughts of our rate powers and we
will
always take it on board and consider it
so thank you very much
thank you cheers
next we have um
reserve advisory group again please come
forward
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thank you so um up to 15
minutes
with you an opportunity for some
questions just to let you know
um you're on audio live stream so as
well
so thank you for your time we look
forward to hearing from you thanks very
much of course uh
um
that would be helpful um our staff can
circulate that to us
there's no trouble
[Applause]
um
[Music]
and other information pertaining to the
application that some of the other
members
may have however um
[Applause]
the submission is around
our desire to secure some funding from
the council
to go towards public facilities
and obviously the reasons
and i've got some similar and also
additional information
um in the handouts here so
um the essay course reserve is has
become an increasingly populous
destination
for visitors from within the district
field
we were seeing international visitors
and things like that
that's the information from our visitors
the facilities there are
top notch basically we've got the
swimwear river up there in nestle and
multiple rivers in the canterbury region
of that status obviously to say uh
prisons including yesterday
further down we've got the camden
facility up next to us
run by uh
[Music]
a little bit further high quality
facilities
and also particularly recently now the
walking tracks being established and
seeing more and more people coming to
use those
and as publicity and people are talking
uh more and more about those tracks
um coming through those and i'll just
add a little bit of information
um so i just wanted to cover a
background
we are seeing increasing number of
visitors at
the reserve and using the facilities of
the
we had a environment recorder
established and we were installed into
the um
blue trek which is a sort of half an
hour
just over the river from the reserve
area itself
over 113 days and there's 527 people
recorded using the track
which suggests we just blew us all away
so that was installed
um because we really want to
keep an eye on um
people are coming to the reserve we're
encouraging people to park in the
reserve
and therefore there'll be extra demand
on facilities within the reserve itself
and people might be making the danger of
it to come for swimming through the walk
and that sort of thing
further to that background information
the council has invested significantly
in you know facilities
thus far at the reserve so
that includes pavilion over 80 thousand
dollars for some discipline
um renovated and
provided that that facility uh it's got
information and
you know
the science invested in walking tracks
and assisted with establishing those and
also facilities and signs in the reserve
we've also had significant input from
the community
we've managed to fundraise over 17 000
within the community um and we've got
over four thousand hours
um you know uh volunteering us
sort of contributed towards the walking
tracks up in the reserve
area and that includes school students
um students doing the chief viewing
award um
people who are from around the area
people coming out from christchurch just
kept doing the work on those treks and
things so it's
there's a really enthusiastic punch uh
you know we're dead
um we're also getting support from the
local business um we see on page three
the handout there is
the bird height as an example
um
one of the key aspects of the submission
is around safety
and we have had members of the
advisory group observe people cooking
in the reserve area so down on each left
but they have been using open fires and
also charcoal fires which
as we know i've done i don't speak them
today actually dropping out here that
the virus was still
very high so three to four if you like
even right now so we want to
encourage people to get away from using
that type of
cooking but we do want people to be able
to cook
that's you know sort of a bit of a key
way of having it
is you can you know throw dinner on the
battery so
we don't want to encourage people to use
unsafe pieces of cooking
um and of course
um as per the um pergola
and you know concrete we think that
would significantly enhance the um
initially um
um provided that from the supplier of
the barbecue so that's the double
barbecue
that we're sort of looking at the
putting the nearby but a single one
just because of the numbers that we are
actually
so um that's really the the guts of uh
our submission um we
have done this as a group um submission
here
so it's not a solid ether by any switch
and
we're all behind them and hoping that we
can enhance the
williams flat area of the reserve and
make it safer for people
you know and the increasing number of
people that come to visit
that's great thank you very much very
clear what you're looking for
and on behalf of the council thank you
to the advisor
for all the work that you do thank you
our questions are colleagues first
[Music]
yes but thank you for letting us know
that thank you councillor wood
um i think it's a great idea i just
wondered with
my question for you have you sort of
approached
and we are expecting to receive uh
significant
assistance from the community you know
through volunteer hours
or maybe other funding sources as well
so i certainly wouldn't know how
but you know i can't continue that at
the moment
thank you okay well look um thank you
and you've got one of the members of me
and shooters anyway
i'm sure you're well connected so um
i don't think you are pretty clear it's
really great booming organizations that
come along that have done a lot towards
the fundraising as well
as you've done so it's fantastic thank
you
and um later part of this month we'll
make a decision
and um let you know on the month of july
for their decision
so just before councillors go i just
would like to raise something with you
so
um we appreciate your time have a great
weekend
can i just thank our staff for their
support over the last three days
particularly um and today of course
kate courtney and vijay um and
there's a cd so thank you um
are we off livestream now
okay so i'm just gonna use so i'm just
gonna use
so i'm just gonna use so i'm just gonna
use so
i'm just gonna use so i'm just gonna use
so
so i'm just gonna use